we are here to make a contribution to
the
incredible work that the salvation is
doing here in the city of las vegas
and as a representative of cox
communications and also being able to
serve on the board
my just incredible privilege to be able
to get behind the salvation army and
help you do the most good in the
community
so in addition to providing some turkeys
for
the clients of yours to enjoy over the
thanksgiving holiday
we would like to also give you a check
for a hundred thousand dollars to help
purchase additional food
rent relief other relief for those that
are in most need here in the community
so anthony on behalf of cox
communications
we want to thank you for your work here
and make this contribution for your
success
thank you so much this is absolutely
amazing
um really a groundbreaking donation
that's going to help us help families
all year long we are so thankful for
this
covet has made it difficult for a lot of
families but we get to help bridge the
gap
because of donations like this thank you
so much fantastic and juan i know that
as the director of this campus here you
will put this to good use as well
we will we're doing that next week for
sure
fantastic david do you want to talk a
little bit about what the james m cox
foundation is
sure the james m cox foundation is
actually a family foundation um
a lot of people don't know that cox
communications is actually a privately
held company
and the cox family um is started over
125 years ago
and so the family had approached um
their businesses and said how can we do
the most good to help those that are
being affected by coven 19 in our
communities
and so because of our involvement with
the salvation army not only here in las
vegas but also in arizona
they came forward and said we would like
to give a quarter million dollars
to help salvation army within the
arizona and las vegas markets
and so a hundred thousand dollars going
here for the las vegas
hundred thousand dollars going into the
phoenix area and another fifty thousand
dollars being contributed to the
salvation army
in southern uh arizona as well
you